NBC's Chris Hansen the guy that used to
catch a predator remember that guy well
this is kind of ironic but the guy known
for catching people was arrested himself
for writing bad checks that's his mug
shot right there yeah yeah and it's kind
of sad you know it is kind of sad but
get this
well that was reading about to catch a
predator I found another more upbeat
story about that old show I don't you
remember this if you were a fan of that
program but remember the cop who used to
dress up like a bush or a shrub remember
that yes shrub cop you yes hide outside
he was camouflaged as a bush or
something and he would NAB the predator
when they came out yes exactly this is a
real thing it used to be a regular part
of the show if you don't remember here's
a clip once he gets his clothes back on
he walks outside and is arrested by that
camouflaged officer that's one of the
weird I remembered seeing that when it
came out it is so freaking strange see
watch it just one more time watch this
yes
okay well I'm bringing this up for a
reason because this is incredible but
that cop that cop was recently honored
at police headquarters here in Los
Angeles and we have the clip take a look
from cop for your years of service and
dedication to the law-enforcement
community we honor you so that's nice
right that's a nice part that's like a
happy part of this of the story of this
show you know there's the down part this
is the up part you'd think it's great
right no it's not because this happened
right after the medal ceremony check it
out
shrug cop was coming out he's going to
be taken down by look at this another
stroke
yeah apparently he was arrested shrub
cop was arrested for bribery he was on
the tape at a time you not shrub cop
yeah
no one's ever said that before but the
story doesn't end there apparently shrub
cop number two had an outstanding
warrant for money laundering so here's
what happened to him this is too bad he
heading out of here between 5:00 and
5:30 if you want to head on down yes yes
he got taken down by fence cop so
obviously I had to look into what
happened to fence cop turns out fence
cop got home and then this happened
exactly
Thanks cop was arrested by entire house
cop
yeah that really happened
and I want to thank you for sticking
with this bit so far now I'm really
happy to report that this whole sad saga
has a very happy ending
the original shrub cop who was released
I mean was who was arrested was released
on a technicality that's right he's here
tonight so let's give a hand to the
original shrub cop he's here thank you
so this whole story really does have a
happy ending or does it actually joke's
on you shrub cop this whole thing was
the sting operation to bust you for
credit card fraud get him boys thanks to
stair cop and person in the audience cop
we have arrested shrub cop
let's get out of here
appreciate appreciate the irony of how
hard it is for stair cop to take the
stairs
can you know I think if I'm ever
arrested by stair cop I'm gonna try and
make a break get far away quickly